Батьківщина? Я не знаю, де тепер моя батьківщина. Тепер у мене немає батьківщини.
83 роки тому її батьківщина була тут. Еллі Гартвіґ народилася у Східній Пруссії.
Але після Другої світової війни німецька батьківщина стала радянською територією.
Після того як Червона Армія завоювала Східну Пруссію, Еллі залишилася одна.
Батька не стало. Матір зникла безвісти. Сестер вивезли в Радянський Союз.
Еллі Гартвіґ було тоді лише десять років.
У нас родина велика була, семеро людей. Всі померли вже.
Всі крім Йозеса.
Вже багато років Еллі доглядає свого важко хворого чоловіка у крихітній однокімнатній квартирі.
Еллі підтримує в Йозесі життя. Йозес дає Еллі опору і сенс життя.
Він - один з небагатьох людей, які знають її справжню історію.
Йозес - родом з Литви, куди свого часу втекла Еллі.
Після війни не було що їсти. Ми ходили і збирали там.
Я і моя подруга поїхали до Литви збирати.
Один литовський фермер прихистив дівчинку.
Еллі пасла корів, за це їй дозволили залишитися і спати на підлозі.
Назад, до Східної Пруссії вона вирішила поки не повертатися.
Моя подруга і каже - один раз поїхали і у нас радянські все забрали.
Подруга каже, більше я не поїду додому.
Забрала мене одна жінка, а потім й інша забрала. І так і жила я.
Коли Литва стала частиною Радянського Союзу, Еллі отримала радянський паспорт.
Вона вивчила литовську мову, стала називати себе Еллітьє
і робила все, щоб ніхто не зрозумів, що вона німкеня.
Дівчина вийшла заміж. Її перший чоловік виявився п'яницею, він бив її і рано помер.
Я навіть не хочу розповідати, як все це було. Все було так складно.
Складними були і відносини між корінним населенням
і новими жителями колишньої німецької території.
Старий Кеніґсберґ став називатися Калінінградом,
коли на початку 60-х Еллі Гартвіґ повернулася зі своїм другим чоловіком Йозесом
на стару батьківщину.
Східна Пруссія тепер російський анклав, закрите місто.
Все німецьке вважалося тут ворожим, ганебним.
Багато так званих російських німців не мали права навчатися у вишах.
Вони вважалися зрадниками, їх називали фашистами.
Еллі Гартвіґ пристосувалася. Як німкеня, вона стає непомітною.
Її сестри живуть тим часом вже в НДР. Однак вона не змогла перебратися до Німеччини.
Я ніколи і нікому це не розповідала. Я завжди говорила, що я литовка.
Це було так важко, про це не можна було говорити.
Еллі Гартвіґ відмовилася від сво го імені, походження.
Історики називають дітей з такими долями дітьми-вовченятами - Wolfskinder.
Безпритульні німецькі діти з колишньої Східної Прусії. Одинаки.
Життя в страху, що інші дізнаються про їхнє походження.
Мої сусідки і зараз гадки не мають, хто я насправді.
Скільки дітей-вовченят ще живі, ніхто сказати не може.
Багато за власним бажанням або вимушено змінили імена.
Еллі - у паспорті Єлєна.
Її німецька така, як і була 70 років тому -
це її єдиний зв'язок з колишньою батьківщиною - Східною Прусією.
Батьківщина, яка існує лише в її піснях.